đã quá World Cup ơi
chơi lớn như Glow up khi bắt Tay World Cup 2.026
phiên bản kem đánh răng vàng gold gay sốt
nay còn thêm combo quà tặng khiến hội Nam mê tít
không ngờ giờ xem thể thao mà cũng được chiều tới vậy
hệ mê bóng đá chưa hết
dần dần với phiên bản kem đánh răng
vàng óng ánh của Glow up
nhìn sang xịn từ bao bì tới chất kem
tưởng vậy là hết
AI ngờ còn tung thêm combo mùa World Cup 2.026
mua 2 tuýp là được tặng kèm quà như tất đá bóng
túi đựng đúng chuẩn chúng team hội mê thể thao
vừa chăm sóc cá nhân vừa bắt vai bóng đá
combo này đúng kiểu dùng hàng ngày mà vẫn thấy có mood
nhất là mấy ngày Theo kèo bóng đá liên tục thì càng hợp
vừa gọn vừa tiện
mấy nàng muốn kiếm quà Cho người yêu mê bóng đá
thì đây đúng là lựa chọn
dễ ghi điểm không cần quá cầu kỳ nhưng vẫn đúng
gu hiểu SAO item này đang được truyền Tay dần dần
vì vừa bắt trend World Cup vừa có quà tặng thiết thực
đúng kiểu một công đôi việc